- [Narrator] These days,
to be an NBA champion,
you're probably gonna need to be
a top three-point shooting team,
and who better to talk
threes then the NBA's
all-time leading three-point shooter, Ray Allen.
- Hi, I'm Ray Allen.
- [Narrator] Yeah, we
know, I already said that.
Our story begins on February 7th, 1945,
back when all shots were
worth a mere two points.
That day, the Columbia University Lions
were picking on the Fordham
Rams in New York City
and the NCAA introduced the
world to the three-point shot.
Basketball would never be the same again,
once the NCAA permanently
adopted the triple in 1986.
The three point shot
mitigated the advantage
taller, stronger players
were, well, born with.
Sure, there were good small players,
but incentivizing shots from distance
leveled the playing field, or
should I say hardwood court.
Fast forward 70 years and the
three-point shot is the shot
and Ray Allen knows this.
Ray is the most prolific three
point shooter in NBA history.
(record scratch)
For now.
- [Ray] What the hell?
- [Narrator] And Ray, like
all basketball greats,
is a student of the game.
When did the three point
shot get introduced
to professional basketball?
- It all started with the
American Basketball Association,
better known as the ABA.
(whistle blowing)
- [Narrator] Timeout.
For all you non-basketball fans out there,
the NCAA is the National
Collegiate Athletic Association.
That's college basketball.
The ABA, a pro league,
was a sort of anti-NBA
until it merged with the NBA in 1976.
(whistle blowing)
Fun.
- [Ray] The ABA featured a
flashier version of basketball
with a colorful ball,
dunks, and of course,
the three-point shot.
- [Narrator] And for that, you can thank
then NBA commissioner George Mikan,
who wanted to --
- Give the smaller
player a chance to score
and open up the defense to make the game
more enjoyable to fans.
- [Narrator] Exactly.
So the NBA adopted it pretty
much right away, right?
- It took awhile.
It wasn't until 1979, when
Boston Celtic Chris Ford,
my first NBA coach, hit
the first three-point shot
in an NBA game.
- [Narrator] The first
of over 380,000 threes
made in NBA history.
We take a break from our
regularly schedule programming
to bring you the art of
the three-point shot,
by Mr. Walter Ray Allen, Jr.
- The key to the three-
point shot is knowing
where you are on the floor
before you get the ball.
Nobody likes a long two.
You need a great knee
bend, and gather yourself.
Next, you need great lift,
straight up and down.
And of course, to top it all off,
you need an immaculate follow through.
It's so easy, anyone can do it.
(ball bounce)
Almost anyone.
C'mon, little buddy, you got this.
Get it in there.
You know, your game might be horseshoes.